all right you ready yeah you ready to do
this yeah all right hey guys I'm Ryan
Wright this is where you say your name
hey I'm Katie they're here there you go
new girl on the channel buzzing hey
actually met her at my work
oh we're gonna doctor's office and she's
one of the patients I was sick and then
I gazed upon her and I was like Katie
yeah I use my pickup line today for my
pickup line oh you're in the movie
business I have a YouTube channel you
should come on it sometime here you are
sucka
obviously I swooned immediately and I
was like this guy is my my lucky ticket
yeah freedom a ticket to wealth and
power I found out she's a little Jewish
isn't that hot that's really good
I grew up Catholic so meaning someone
who's Jewish is like oh yes that's the
word only Jews get that got to mention
we're gonna watch the extended TV spot
of a movie Katie is really looking
forward to transformers age of
extinction
you can almost said it wrong extension
thinks want Optimus Prime extends get it
uh get it it's a penis joke yeah no I'm
really glad you put that together for us
this is like the first time I really got
in to meet her spoken ever ever
you take all the times we've talked at
my job that accumulates to nothing
compared to this is the most we've ever
spoken yeah I'm definitely getting
uncomfortable I told you I wouldn't kill
you before you came over you can try I
mean I I brought my knife I you didn't
have to bring the knife Katie you know
what I should kill you I should kill you
right now like I said you can try oh man
uh-huh once this video is done she's
dead I texted my friend with this
address and I said if you don't work for
me this is where I died but it's almost
verbatim when I said to her did you
I'm not about to be you know taken to a
second location and locked up and
Elizabeth's smarted yeah you know I did
that once when um Wow
what was her spark
I was a little late on now well you
should probably watch this I'm ready
this is what the glasses come off
oh that's okay I was wondering it's like
a transformation for transformers ready
to get extinct or something I'll give a
[ __ ] what you say this [ __ ] looks cool
man
yeah
explosion
they're back
we imagine dragons I guess there are in
the movie now oh my god mark Wohlers
yeah man whoa
oh my god oh my god okay if it's like
dinosaurs
bullies are writing it yeah that's that
looks amazing
do you get it like imagine dragons like
it's like it sort of like dragons but I
do like dinosaurs
well they're farmers they're real
they're real band is that is that it
that's it it's a TV spot I know that
looks pretty cool that was the best
trailer I've seen for this one man I'm
surprised oh wow yes you like we
probably just saw all the best parts
maybe those movies are tend to be
jam-packed with like three hours of
action that's true and Mark Wahlberg I'm
not taking a shirt off or something do
you like Mark Wahlberg I mean you know
I'm not like with him but he's cool it
looks like is this gonna be a fun time
and it looks like they might have
improved it in some ways yeah please
just a trailer you know there's just a
lot of plot holes that I really I feel
you could drive Optimus Prime through
drive if there's like a decent plot I
will probably be okay with it because it
looked like a lot of like pretty awesome
dinosaur style fighting yeah no I
totally agree yeah there it is like
imagining a dragon dude you nailed that
one get it I nailed that one this is how
I make girls comfortable when they come
into my home you make me completely mean
they're both I was awful why did I do
that I told you not to insult me Katie I
don't want to hurt you but if you put me
in a position to I will are you
threatening me
no what every time a girl gets mad it's
the most terrifying experience in the
world that's really intelligent and it's
probably the smartest thing you know oh
that reminds me you have a doctor's
appointment tomorrow I do thank you yeah
you're gonna call didn't you yeah I call
I asked you I called it I was gonna need
your reminder call yeah and then I was
like well it probably that was probably
what it was so that's good ten o'clock
and what 11 o'clock okay [ __ ] yeah
anyway guys if you're new to this
channel get this button up here just
subscribe that's what there's this
subscribe it's actually right here you
known you for 20 minutes and it's been
the most frustrating 20 minutes of my
life yeah I tend to
so we're gonna shout out Katie huh Big
Show what's up man he wanted to shout
out I like your name big show yo put on
a more appropriate behavior while we're
shining out now that was rude okay I'm
sorry Big Show this was supposed to be
the perfect shout out but Katie likes to
just ruin everything
I earned it I'm so sorry with the
disrespect and stuff Big Show you're
great and um that's that's that's great
that you're great you're like fixing
yourself while we're talking to this guy
well I feel like I have some dead skin
on my lip sorry
oh but you know she ant Tamplin yeah can
Taplin hmm can dammit I just imagine
Caine now all this church talk I feel
like yeah I feel like that's a that's an
Irish name oh maybe maybe a Gaelic name
really Scottish they're probably just
like so pissed right now
is it a weird Gaelic it's like how how
unfortunate you know so that's not it's
no it's true it sure would it be
unfortunate it's gay is a different word
in hey look what is it I don't know how
do you know this cuz why would it be the
same word look it up I spell the word
gay likert-type
DIY and then space GAE LIC Gaelic gay in
Gaelic I was know you're just gonna find
gay Gaelic stuff whatever Chi and Tapley
man [ __ ] this man I don't know what
you're making us do this war but cut the
[ __ ] I'm sorry you don't know how to say
gang Gaelic can you do sensors can you
sensor I'm feet no man this show is
uncensored you get sick stuff like [ __ ]
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] okay well then she
is she's what yeah yeah whatever I got
Zayas universal Church Trajan's my man
universal creations this guy thinks he's
God ya know for sure that might be God I
hear you God's a big fan of the channel
might be Jesus in the flesh but that is
so no it's not Jesus is a huge fan of
the channel Jesus is
busy making tables jesus's everywhere
tam management talking with jewish
people about this is really difficult to
win